[Music]
I'm Molly bloom do you know about me
this is a true story
you ran a games in LA for roughly eight
years yeah you ran into New York for
Russia - I don't run a game in over two
years not to spoil the ending but that's
when the government raided my game and
took all of my money assuming all of it
was made illegally which it wasn't in
this room you couldn't buy your win from
Allah you couldn't buy me then you
couldn't buy a seat at the table when we
start athletes bidding as that's just a
tip of the iceberg
you're not taking percentage of the pot
no keep it that way because you don't
break the law when you're breaking the
law
am I breaking off we're able to find out
for sure
aren't we flaws are written down yeah I
mean is any way about your book of life
right I did you spent eight years buying
the world's most exclusive glamorous and
decadent man okay for the office
guarantee the publisher has certain
elements and I can get you a million and
a half what kind of elements
I passed I'm just curious as to why you
pass on what would appear to be the only
way out you have these real names
creative differences the law that I'm
accused of breaking the plans gambling
is betting on games of chance yes pokers
in a game of chance poker is a game of
skill
why does a young woman at 22 has a
gold-plated resume
why does she run her games risk is nuts
you're gonna get blown up
you got 2.8 million on the street right
now if that money should be in your
hands just out deep into the Russian mob
where you
you offer on the table completely we
handle it Audra you seen what's on those
hard drives family's lives careers will
be really why are you in this alone
where are the people you're protected by
not setting the whole story it's not
their names I'm protecting charlie my
because it's not me
[Music]
you
[Music]